alright that was the president reacting
to this week's impeachment hearings and
a bunch of other stuff and we're gonna
wait for today's second hearing to start
Department of Defense official Laura
Cooper and David Hale State Department
official will be testifying in a little
bit earlier today ambassador to the EU
Gordon Sandland facing off with
lawmakers he whipped Democrats and Amina
into a huge frenzy when he said this in
his opening statement I know that
members of this committee frequently
framed these complicated issues in the
form of a simple question was there a
quid pro quo as I testified previously
with regard to the requested White House
call and the White House meeting the
answer is yes after Sandlin said that
Adam Schiff quickly ran to the media
microphones to declare victory in case
closed but then the Ambassador had to
answer actual questions and it turns out
his story has some major holes here's
just one example there were so many
different scenarios floating around as
to what was going on with Ukraine so
rather than ask the president nine
different questions is that this is that
this is that that I just said what do
you want from Ukraine I may have even
used a four-letter word and he said I
want nothing I want no quid pro quo I
just want Solinsky to do the right thing
to do what here an honours or words to
that effect
Dayna yes sir today was a very confusing
day for everybody Soglin was confused
himself from my understanding it looks
like he comes out and he says there was
a quid pro quo he was talking about a
White House meeting mm-hmm president
wanted a White House meeting but not
until they announced an investigation
into the 2016 elections and into BER
yzma so that's not a crime is just PR
for PR that had nothing to do with
military aid and at the end of the day
maybe this blockbuster testimony wasn't
as blockbuster as people well like with
most days of this testimony I have heard
from friends on the Left who say slam
dunk amazing we did so well today and
from
publicans who say it's over no problem
this guy was a total joke so I think
both sides will try to tell their story
and what we can get into all of that
I felt like during the hearing that the
Democrats were excited to have him yeah
and then they're like wait no we're not
so excited and then it was like the
Republicans and the Democrats got so
frustrated with him and he was just
there saying I just was trying to do my
best
he's not a note-taker right and his
memory as human memories can be faulty
he's like I'm not exactly sure the dates
and the times and the cost plus the
State Department won't allow him to
access his records so he can't actually
go back and look at it so the members of
Congress are so frustrated and then you
get to this question from representative
Turner did no one on this planet told
you Trump was trying to aid
ditalion aide to investigators yes or no
and he says yes no one ever told me that
and I think the Republicans will try to
say there we go
now you we saw I talked about polls
earlier today like the the polls on
impeachment are not going in the
Democrats favor right at all and well
maybe I should say at all on the ones
that we've seen so far especially like
in Wisconsin an important battleground
state right eight percentage points more
than before do people say we don't think
impeachments the thing that doesn't
necessarily mean he's gonna win although
he's up against all the other possible
opponents but I think that if you have a
persuade you don't have many persuadable
Democrats are gonna say he's guilty the
Republicans are gonna say he's not but
for the people that are in the middle I
don't think it's going to be very
effective for Republicans go out and say
perfect call no problem here I think
they need some sort of an off-ramp so
they could say they've got to the
Ukrainians we support the Ukrainians we
are for this for our national security
we want to continue to do this this is
not right this does not rise to an
impeachable offense and I think that's
where the Republicans would probably be
most successful after this test and they
may get an off-ramp from the IG report
and Durham which puts it all into
perspective Greg yes did you wake up at
9:00 and watch the hearings minute by
minute well first I woke up at 9:00 and
then I walked home
no I yeah I I spent a lot of time trying
to figure out why I understand this
better than most people in the media and
it's because I ran stuff for a living
right if you manage
we talked about this earlier Dana in
your office we talked about how anybody
who's involved in management which means
hiring or firing or dealing with budgets
dealing with Human Resources we look at
this and we're going like wow this is
just how the world works and then you
understand that how so many people in
the media they don't have a talent stack
right they have a very Davis singular
vertical experience from journalism in
high school journalism in college being
promoted through the ranks as a
journalist they don't have a collection
of versatile skills so they don't you
understand it's like why why journalists
are so bad with writing about businesses
and writing about the economy is they
have no financial backgrounds they're
pathetic right and the people whose
hairs are on fire on Twitter the media
reporters generally have almost no
experience whatsoever in the outside
world they have date they don't go to an
office and have to deal with polite
people asking for raises or having to
cut staff so when it comes to issues
about business or employment or human
interaction they're abject failures so I
use this example there is a period in
your life as a businessman where your
personal goals and your professional
goals coincide right Joe Biden is a
political rival you investigate him he
benefit benefits the country and it and
it benefits the leader that is where a
professional and a personal goal
coincides likewise we have a great hair
and makeup staff at the 5:00
personally it makes me look great
professionally it helps the show because
if I look good the show does better if I
look like a slob it doesn't in this case
the personal and the professional goals
coincide when you're the President of
the United States and you're dealing
with a person who may be dealing with a
corrupt country a known corrupt country
in the past possibly in the future if
they benefit you to investigate him but
it benefits the country as well ain't no
crime Wow just a fun time bond would you
like to respond to that
I agree Greg says why I think this was I
do look good though one there's no
question you
you look marvelous I think this was a
bad day for a president Trump and you
know one way to to look at it is always
to check out what other people are
saying so today I was with Dana we were
doing the coverage and I noticed that
Ken Starr and Andy McCarthy both thought
Trump had a bad day especially after
that first the morning session when you
heard directly from ambassador sauna it
was dramatic in terms of that damning
opening statement it was clear that he
was saying was there a quid pro quo as
you played in the soundbite Jessie he
said yes and if he had not said that
there was a quid pro quo it would have
been absolutely deflating for the
Democrats this was what the Democrats
had advertises this is going to be our
Johnny and this is going to be a key
moment afterwards Adam Schiff said this
was a seminal moment today and that's
what it turned out to be what was the
quid pro quo for Katie it wasn't with
the military a sort of a song no one
details especially for journalists
really matters so the opening statement
in the morning when he says there's a
quid pro quo he admitted this was
something that he was presuming to be
happening and he was saying that it was
with people working for Trump later in
the afternoon he then said directly the
president has never told me to engage in
a quid pro quo he hasn't asked me for
that directly he's never said those
things so while he inferred from people
he was working with overseas that maybe
that's what was being asked for he
didn't implicate the president directly
as an order coming directly from the
White House but that being said I don't
think Adam Schiff really cares about any
of the facts or whether they are good or
bad for Republicans he is moving this
thing forward no matter what happens he
ran to the cameras during that break to
talk about articles of impeachment that
he must put forward guarantee you he's
gonna write one up on bribery and the
other one up on obstruction of Congress
because he talked about it today whether
they're valid or not and so get ready
house because Adam Schiff is driving the
train and you're going along for the
ride and they're gonna impeach him for
tweeting also remember that Mary
impeachable